there are many many many many fake
environments in the world but Sports you
can't fake last night the Jets played
they lost another game that happened to
happen yesterday was the Dolphins got
their face beaten Sports the Dolphins
can't wake up today and be like oh we
did it but you can do that in corporate
it's fake in a lot of places on Earth
Sports is not fake the closest thing to
sports is entrepreneurship your business
either works or it doesn't you either
make money or you don't it either stays
alive or goes out of business I want
everyone to be an entrepreneur if they
are one but for a lot of people they're
a number two two they're number four
they're number eight and that's amazing
I don't want people to be entrepreneurs
I want people to be self-aware to figure
out what makes them happy and live that
life a lot of people have struggled with
failing in front of everyone when you're
not built for it and then all of a
sudden you go for it and then it fails
that's failure in front of everyone and
the one reason that most people don't do
entrepreneurship is they do fear
failure